qui fait son retour à kiev dès ce soir
20 heures les habitants ne pourront plus
sortir jusqu'à mercredi matin c'est une
manière de les protéger mais aussi de
traquer des infiltrés russe john allan
walsh a pu suivre sur la question une
mission de police dans la gare centrale
de kiev écouter
nous avons pu observer avec avec la
police l'unité que nous avons suivi ce
matin ce qui est l'autre inquiétude
l'autre principale inquiétude ici à la
fois pour les forces de sécurité et pour
la population ce sont ceux qu'on appelle
les saboteurs autrement dit les
infiltrés russe que ce soient des
espions ou des combattants qui qui sont
qui sont téléguidés par par moscou et
c'est vraiment la hantise ici deux de la
police de l'armée on le sait ils ont été
très actif en particulier au début au
début de l'invasion russe au début de la
guerre et nous avons donc fait le tour
de la gare nous avons traversé toute la
gare avec cette unité qui avait à la
fois des chiens pour pour détecter des
explosifs dans les sacs et puis et puis
toute une brigade qui était chargée de
contrôler les papiers des gens qui
arrivaient en train ou qui repartaient
car c'est ça peut paraître assez
étonnant mais les lignes ferroviaires
continue à fonctionner en ukraine malgré
la guerre et servent notamment à la
population de kiev à fuir la capitale
pour ceux qui veulent partir vers
l'ouest de l'ukraine et même à
l'étranger et puis ça permet aussi de
ravitailler partiellement la ville de
kiev et de faire venir les volontaires
qui s'engagent dans la défense
territoriale ici dans la capitale